in my lab I can think of three things
that we've done that have kind of been I
think you know and I don't say it to
credit myself because the a lot of
credit goes to the students and postdocs
who did this research in many cases they
came up with these ideas but one was the
rediscovery of something called
reconsolidation which is when you
retrieve a memory it becomes unstable
and new information can be incorporated
into the memory at that point it also
means that when the memory is unstable
its restabilization process can be
blocked and if you block that the memory
is weakened or dampened so that's how
we've been using reconsolidation to help
people with traumatic memories and try
and dampen their memories of those
traumatic situations not necessarily the
conscious cognitive memories but the
emotional component of the memory so
that's one area that that I think we've
had a big impact in and Kareem Nader
really gets credit for for triggering
all of that research in my lab another
area is a take off on that which is a
recent study that we published by the
Murray mo feel is the lead author
showing that we could take what's
usually called exposure therapy where
it's also called extinction where you
give your condition a rat to be afraid
of something then you give the tone over
and over again and it stops being afraid
and this is also used in the treatment
of phobias and other kinds of anxiety
problems by weakening the the fear
associations that the trigger the
emotion but the problem is that the fear
always bounces back at some point say by
stress so the patient has a fear of
heights and then his or her mother dies
and the fear of heights comes back even
though it was successfully treated but
we found a way in rats to prevent that
bounce back of the fear we can more or
less permanently dampen in it and that
has to do with a special procedure in
which the extinction process is timed in
a certain way and it's too complicated
to explain in detail but by simply by
timing certain presentations of the
stimuli
extinction can be made to be more more
permanent and a third area which is kind
of a technical advance Jos Johansson has
recently published a study in my lab
using optogenetics which is a new way of
altering brain activity by what you do
is you connect up a molecule that you're
interested in with a virus so that it
can be injected into the brain and
altered genes in that brain area and
what we've been injecting our molecules
that that are light-sensitive so that
you inject this this virus into the
brain it puts a molecule in that part of
the brain that then when you later
implant a small fiber-optic lamp in
there it's very tiny it's just you know
it's it's microscopic but it goes right
into the amygdala and when you shine a
flashlight on the amygdala it it causes
the neurons in the amygdala to be
responsive to light and to depolarize so
they have action potentials when the
light shines on them and what this
allowed us to do was to test the basic
idea that learning in the brain or
learning in this case in the amygdala
but in the brain in general involves the
depolarization depolarization of neurons
but in other words the firing of action
potentials while the neuron is getting a
meaningless stimulus so what we did is
we presented the rat with the tone while
we directly depolarized the lateral
amygdala cells with the light and this
created learning in that the form of in
the form of behavior when the rats later
heard the tone so this is a very
important technical advance showing that
a very basic principle of synaptic
plasticity called heavy and learning
after Donald Hebb who said that learning
involves the arrival of a weak synaptic
input at a time when a strong synaptic
input is activating the same cell so in
our case the weak synaptic input is the
tone and the strong synaptic input is
the
depolarization of the cells this
depolarization obviously substitutes for
the electric shock that we would
normally give in a conditioning
experiment so those are I think three
things that we've done that have been
important not enough that they're the
most important things in neuroscience
but I'm drawing a blank of the